the acting deputy secretary of homeland
security ken cuccinelli joins us now
uh mr secretary thank you so much for
being with us i i want to start with the
report
with you good morning i want to start
with the reporting that ben just gave us
we have two cabinet secretaries who
have resigned other members of the
administration have you yourself
considered resigning
i've stayed at my post doing the public
safety work that we're doing at the
department of homeland security and i
expect to continue to do that
we were critical to supporting the
capitol police who were the primary
authority responsible for the response
on wednesday but we sent hundreds of
officers over there
and i was authorizing a lot of that
activity for dhs we're planning for a
safe inauguration we expect
a safe inauguration and america can
expect a safe inauguration and that's
really what we're focused on right now
that's reassuring
as we reported some cabinet members have
have reportedly discussed using the 25th
amendment would you support that
i'm not aware of any such discussions
i've heard of nothing
like that inside the government of
course this week i've been focused on
the public safety aspects of our role at
dhs
but uh you know the the 12th amendment
says unable to serve i guess they can
decide what that means but
i don't see any i don't see unable i see
that people are upset
and the speaker made her comments but
there is a there's a long way to go to
to meet the constitutional requirement
and you saw vice president pence
um stick with his understanding which i
think is the right one
of the constitutional role that he had
to play which was
not to have any role in doing much more
than counting
the electoral votes from the states and
that's what the 12th amendment calls for
i expect he's going to be just as true
to every other part of the constitution
do you not believe the president had a
role in inciting this riot
uh well for six or seven months we've
been calling on people on both sides to
condemn
violence where it occurs and in the
middle of the
in the middle of the problem at the
capitol on wednesday we did get that
tweet from the president
calling on people to leave the capitol
to be peaceful to respect the police
officers and so forth
um so that was obviously helpful it was
a stronger statement yesterday
and i would note that this
administration is pursuing justice
against those folks
and unlike other parts of the country
portland is an obvious comparison
the district of columbia the federal
government in many respects acts like
the local government so
unlike say the prosecutor in portland
who lets lots of rioters go without
charges
that is not happening here the fbi is
fully pursuing
anyone they can find who is involved in
this criminal activity
and we at dhs are assisting them in that
they have the point
and there's no restraint on that we are
fully
across the administration pursuing every
avenue of justice available
why was the response so slow to this mr
secretary
well that's an excellent question and
the capitol police
are in a unique position the only other
similar
police force in the district of columbia
is the supreme court police
the capitol police report only to
congress
and the supreme court police report only
to the court
it is that branch of government's own
police force
we were moving uh folks secret service
agents in particular
over before the violence began but that
has to come
at the request of the capitol police
because they have jurisdiction there
and so when they made that request we
moved as quickly as we could and secret
service agents federal protective
service agents
moved to support them and in literally
in the hundreds
so uh that that did happen but the
problem of course is
the initial breach and there was no
backup behind that
and it does appear that there was
inadequate preparation
and numbers by the capitol police they
were overwhelmed by a few hundred folks
and uh and that shouldn't happen now on
the positive they kept all the members
safe
which is which is even more important
than the building of course
um that is the priority and the vice
president was never in danger
um thanks to both capitol police and the
secret service so but the building was
breached
that shouldn't have happened there'll be
an intensive review of that and you've
already seen speaker pelosi
fire the house sergeant-at-arms and the
capitol police chief
and i i have to say i agree with her in
that action this is a leadership failure
that put inappropriate pressure on
individual officers
which puts them in a very very difficult
position and of course we've now
know we've lost one of those officers
because of injuries acting deputy
secretary
cuccinelli thank you so much